I was actually enjoying the Army and
then I went down to you know all the
recruiting stations are usually like
back to back I talked to him he gives me
weird Vibes then I went to the Navy and
that guy kind of gave me like used car
salesman Vibes and then I went to the
marine recruiter and I was like hello
hello and then there was no one there
I'm like what the [__] she's empty and
then this guy comes out from underneath
the desk he's like trying to join the
Marines I was like oh I think I found my
people
yeah the Montebello dare you're just
killing all my credit building here
right now
uh PE shorts he goes all right make this
quick cause I gotta go coach wrestling
dude this guy doesn't give a [__] about
me I like him